a flashback to penny wises origins are
floating dream sequence and graphic
scenes from the original script are just
some of the things that were cut from
the final version of it
chapter one yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
it's Jan here and today I'm delving into
some of the horrifying scenes script
changes and rejected concepts we never
got to see in the new it's movie and
I'll also be explaining how we can
expect to see a number of these deleted
storylines appear in the movie sequel my
penny wise Funko pop giveaway is also
running on this video so for a chance to
win make sure you subscribe to my
channel and leave a comment below with
your thoughts about the movie or any of
the cutscenes spoiler warning I'm going
to discuss scenes from the movie and
speculate on the sequel so take care if
you haven't seen it yet given Henry
Bowers repeated unhinged acts of cruelty
in the film it's safe to say most of the
audience will have been glad to see him
get some sort of comeuppance however
there were a couple of deleted scenes
that director Andy machete revealed in
an interview with vulture that he says
would have brought some humanity to
Henry the director explained that the
scenes depicted the conflict that Henry
has at home with his father
how and why Henry is a monster the main
reason being that he was physically
abused by his dad this additional
backstory for Henry would have been in
keeping with the character's abusive
father and Stephen King's novel but
although machete wanted to include
Henry's backstory in the film he found
that in test screenings people didn't
react as he expected and didn't seem
interested in the background to the
bully's sadistic behavior so he decided
to cut the scenes from the final film
still while the scenes were deleted that
made clear Henry's abused by his father
behind closed doors one scene which
hints at his father's behavior did make
us into the final movie and that's the
scene where Henry shoots his dad's gun
two other scenes that the director
wanted to include in the shoot ended up
being cut from filming as they needed
more CGI and the movie was on a tight
budget of around thirty-five million
dollars the first scene given the chop
was a flashback that showed the first
time when the evil entity it came into
contact with human beings the scene that
machete could be referencing appears in
some of the original scripts for the
movie and shows a young mother in 17th
century Derry making a deal with penny
wise who tells her that unless she gives
him her baby
he'll kill ever
everyone she strikes a deal and so the
cycle of it in Derry Maine begins in the
new movie we do see been in the losers
Club looking at photos and articles
about old dairy which indicate that is
has been around a long time but we still
don't know exactly where the malevolent
creature actually came from or any real
details about its background machete has
said that in the sequel he wants the
character of Mike to play a more active
part in discovering the answer to
defeating Pennywise an idea he's looking
at is for Mike to become addicted to a
substance which then opens up his mind
and allows him to see Pennywise in the
macro verse this would be a spin on the
chapter in King's novel where the losers
Club built a Native American smoke hole
in the hopes that they'll have a vision
that will in cover the truth about it
which is what happens to Mike and Richey
who end up having hallucinations that
reveal the origins of it the second
scene that was cut from filming was a
dream sequence that took place in Derry
basically Bill is leaning on a bridge
spitting into the stream below when out
of nowhere he spots a balloon reflected
in the water at that point he looks up
and sees that there's a whole load of
balloons above him and then he notices
that there are also body parts and as a
shot pulls out wider he sees there are
actually dozens of dead kids just
floating in the air
given that machete has talked about the
floating body scene and Pennywise his
origin seen as being postponed we might
well see both of them in the sequel to
be honest though I'm not sorry that
Bill's dreamlike scene of floating
bodies ended up being canceled in the
first movie as I think that seeing that
would have taken away from the impact of
the last part of the film where we
finally see Pennywise is subterranean
lair and the many dead bodies floating
around the Horde of toys and belongings
miss various victims another casualty of
keeping the movie on budget was a scene
featuring the black spot witch in King's
novel was a club mainly frequented by
black customers an early script included
a flashback to the club which was burned
down by racists during one of penny wise
as recurring rains of terror but in the
final movie the black spot is merely
mentioned in passing still although it
was cut from the first movie according
to producer Barbara machete their
current plan is to open the sequel with
the sequence dealing with events at the
black spot of course we'll have to wait
a while to see if that's actually what
happens but in the meantime what I do
think is interesting in this movie is
the way the film may
because have chosen to change Mike's
backstory from the novel in the film
Mike's parents died in a house fire and
the encounter he experiences with penny
wise begins with a fire and hands
desperately reaching around a chained
door trying to get free so I'm thinking
that in the sequel the filmmakers may
connect in some way the death of Mike's
parents with the tragedy at the black
spot which in the novel was witnessed by
Mike's father Mike first encounters
penny wise when he goes to make a
delivery to a butcher's shop in Derry
and after the delivery door bursts open
he sees the clown's evil yellow eyes
from behind a plastic person in the meat
storage area and there's some
behind-the-scenes footage of an
alternate or extended scene where penny
wise is shown thrashing around and
feasting on what looks like a body
behind the plastic screen now this scene
a penny wise devouring a body at the
butchers would perhaps have added more
shock value to Mike's first encounter
with it though you could argue that just
seeing him standing there in the final
film is actually more creepy but I think
the reason this moment may have been
cursed is that if you notice to the
right of penny wise there's a yellow
figure which gives the impression it
might be Georgie hanging in his yellow
raincoat in the final film Georgie has
gone missing but no body has been found
so bill continues to believe his little
brother could still be alive which is a
major motivation for him throughout the
movie so by deleting this extra moment
of penny wise at the butchers it helps
the film preserve that air of mystery
around Georgie's disappearance I've
already talked about the black spot
scene which was in an early script but
ended up being Kurt well that screenplay
was actually written by cary fukunaga
and chase palmer
in fact Fukunaga was also the film's
original director before he quit the
project in 2015 over creative
differences with the studio which led to
the machete siblings taking over as
director and producer of the final movie
palmer of Fukunaga still retained the
first two screenplay credits and the
final movie is still significantly based
on their script however the story does
appear to have changed somewhat in tone
and some of the more graphic scenes from
their script have either been toned down
or cut from the final film one example
of the more shocking tone that Fukunaga
was going for was
Stan's first scene at the synagogue in
the final film stan has an unsettling
encounter with it in the form of a
strange woman from a painting however in
Fukunaga script stan excuses himself in
the rabbi as he needs to go to the
toilets when he can't find the bathroom
he decides to go inside the mikveh a
place for ritual cleansing used for
example by women after their period as
he's about to pee in the pool a naked
woman rises out of the water and starts
to tempt him while she touches herself
however she's actually a rotting
bleeding corpse covered in sores and as
she emerges from the water she says to
Stan come float with me also in the
final movie there's a scene where Babs
father piously about to sexually assault
his daughter something it's implied that
he's done in the past but in Fukunaga
screenplay there's little room left for
doubt for example in his script Bev's
father throws her into his bedroom
demands to know whether she's still a
virgin and orders her to undress and
then begins to talk in a penny wise
voice you'll like it bevy be like you're
floating there are also reports of other
graphic content in Fukunaga scripts
involving young characters such as a
bully Henry committing best reality with
the sheep however this doesn't appear in
the scripts it emerged after the first
trailer was released so it's unclear
what the reports are accurate or not
after you quit the project Fukunaga said
in an interview with Variety that New
Line Cinema were watering down the movie
to make it more conventional and
inoffensive which he said was impossible
to do with a Stephen King novel
as for the machete siblings they've said
they weren't prevented from pursuing
adult themes in the movie however they
added that they did have personal limits
for how far they wanted to push some
scenes or ideas for example in an
interview with Mad movies magazine they
said they cut a scene of a kid being
thrown into the toilets after having his
back broken because they felt it was
really too much to portray visually
speaking of things that are way too much
that seems to be the general consensus
of the filmmakers on that controversial
WTF scene from King's original novel
which features a young Bev having sex
with each of the other young losers in
turn both the machetes and Fukunaga
decided to steer clear of portraying
this moment which happens in the book
after the losers have defeated it but a
loss trying to find their way out of the
sewers King has defended the scene
saying that he wasn't really thinking of
the sexual aspect of it and the
book dealt with childhood and adulthood
and the sexual act connected the to the
machete siblings have explained they
didn't think that the scene was
necessary for the story and it wouldn't
have worked on screen and they also
added that the blood oath the losers
make at the end is a much more
meaningful way to show how the group of
United have matured enough to conquer
their fears and it in his script
Fukunaga actually did a totally
non-sexual version of the scene which
showed Bev stopping the losers from
bickering of forcing them to focus by
simply holding each of their faces in
her hands one by one
there isn't an end credits scene in it
but there is a little maniacal laugh by
penny wise at the very end of the
credits teasing this is is still out
there and will be back in Chapter two
however there were rumors of a short
scene involving Jessica Chastain as the
older Beth who 27 years later receives a
message that is has returned
although producer Barbara machete says
this didn't happen she admits that they
love Jessica Chastain to play the older
Bev in the sequel especially given their
experience of working with her on their
debut feature Mumma and the fact that
Chastain looks similar to Sophia Lillis
who plays young Bev another actress many
would like to see play the adult Bev is
Amy Adams and I thought there was a
really interesting nod to that
possibility in the movie when Beth puts
on the pharmacist glasses and he tells
her she looks a lot like Lois Lane who
of course has been played on the big
screen most recently by Amy Adams so
what did you think of it and is there
anything Cutt or deleted that you wish
have been in the movie and what do you
want to see happen in the sequel let me
know in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to my channel as well for a
chance to win a penny wise Funko pop
I'll announce the winner on an upcoming
video but just before you float off
check out my freaky facts and secrets
about the making of the new it movie tap
the screen here for that or more of my
movie deleted scenes videos thanks for
watching and see you next time you
became movie lovers